Yo les potes !
On est là pour ce nouvel ASK, ASK numéro
5 et on va répondre à la question d’un
d’entre vous :
Qu'est ce que c'est l'ouverture d'esprit ? Et comment être ouvert d'esprit ? Sinon, chouette
vidéo sur l'IA. Merci.
Être ouvert d’esprit c’est une expression,
qui d’ailleurs n’est pas uniquement française
puisqu’on dit en anglais “to be open-minded”,
c’est pour vous dire à quel point cette
expression a du sens. Bref c’est une expression
et si on cherche dans le larousse on voit
que l’ouverture d’esprit c’est l’aptitude
à comprendre des questions diverses et nouvelles,
et à admettre des points de vues opposés.
Donc il y a non seulement une idée de tolérance
mais c’est une idée de tolérance améliorée
puisqu’on va jusqu’à comprendre les autres
et non seulement les admettre. Dans un premier
temps, avant de prendre en compte cette partie
“compréhension”, parlons simplement de
tolérance. Je pense que le plus simple c’est
d’abord de dire ce que ce n’est pas. L’intolérance
tire son origine dans les instincts les plus
primaires de l’homme. Instinctivement on
a peur et on rejette ce qui est différent
de nous et de notre “tribu”. Et ça peut
être beaucoup de choses comme un mode de
vie, une religion, une couleur de peau, etc.
Donc on va voir le monde à travers le prisme
de sa communauté d’origine. C’est souvent
inconscient comme phénomène d’ailleurs.
C’est ce qu’on appelle l’éthnocentrisme,
c’est notamment développé par Claude Levi-Strauss
et c’est ce qui nous pousse à penser que
notre communauté d’origine est supérieure
aux autres. Et cette notion de supérieur
est très importante car en fait elle implique
que tout ce qui est différent est vu comme
inférieur. Bref vous connaissez l’égocentrisme,
le fait de se mettre au centre de tout, et
bien l’ethnocentrisme c’est de mettre
son ethnie, sa société, sa culture, au centre
de tout. Donc la tolérance ça va être de
se défaire un peu de ce prisme là et d’accepter
et de comprendre qu’on puisse voir la vie
selon d’autres prismes. Ce qui explique
que l'intolérance est souvent liée à l'ignorance,
on ne connaît pas donc on a peur donc on
rejette et ici on a déjà les clefs de réponses
pour la 2nd partie de la question, mais on
verra ça après.
Bon ça c’est pour la tolérance. Alors
c’est quoi exactement la différence avec
l’ouverture d’esprit ? Quelqu’un ouvert
d’esprit va faire un effort de compréhension.
C’est à dire qu’il ne veut pas simplement
accepter la différence d’autrui et ne la
voir que comme différence et non y voir une
infériorité par exemple, mais il va aussi
comprendre cette différence là c’est à
dire qu’il va pouvoir changer son repère
ethnocentrique l’espace d’un instant.
Pour reprendre un évènement récent, c’est
celui qui comprends à quel point les caricatures
du prophète peuvent heurter les musulmans.
Et là on parle bien de comprendre. Comprendre
ce n’est pas être d’accord avec, ni ne
pas être d’accord, non ça ça vient plus
tard, mais la première étape c’est de
comprendre. L’ouverture d’esprit c’est
d’avoir cette démarche systématiquement
et on comprends tout de suite qu’une société
qui a ses membres ouverts d’esprit fonctionne
beaucoup mieux puisqu’elle comprend les
intérêts mutuels de ses membres. L’ouverture
d’esprit est donc très importante d’un
point de vue de société, mais aussi d’un
point de vue personnel car c’est en se confrontant
à d’autres idées et d’autres perspectives
que les siennes, que l’on peut espérer
s’élever et affiner ses idées.
Maintenant une question qu’on peut se poser
sur la tolérance, c’est jusqu’où elle
doit aller. ça fait forcément penser à
la citation de Voltaire “Je ne suis pas
d’accord avec ce que vous dites mais je
me battrais pour que vous puissiez le dire.”
qui n’est pas de lui et qui va même à
l’encontre de sa pensée. La citation est
de Evelyn Beatrice Hall, écrivain anglaise,
qui a mit des guillemets alors qu’elle aurait
pas dû. Bref passons l’anecdote. Pourquoi
Voltaire n’est pas d’accord avec ça ? Et
bien pour des raisons très proches de celles
de Popper qui nous parle du paradoxe de la
tolérance qui dit que : “La tolérance
illimitée doit mener à la disparition de
la tolérance.”. En gros ce qu’il dit
c’est que si on tolère tout, alors on va
même jusque tolérer l’intolérant et si
on ne défend pas notre société face à
eux, elle pourrait tomber toute entière dans
l’intolérance et donc on détruirait la
tolérance. L’histoire lui a donné raison,
c’est ce qui s’est passé avec le nazisme.
C’est très simple en théorie mais beaucoup
plus difficile en pratique puisqu’on est
en train de travailler sur des notions qui
ne sont pas tout à fait objectives. La frontière
entre le tolérant et l’intolérant n’est
pas extrêmement nette. Je précise d’ailleurs
que Popper ne dit pas qu’il faut toujours
empêcher les intolérant de s’exprimer,
non, il dit juste qu’il faut revendiquer
le droit de le faire.
Pour ce qui est de comment être ouvert d’esprit,
la réponse découle de ce qu’on a définit
plus tôt. On a dit qu’il y avait rejet
car il y avait peur, et qu’il y avait peur
car il y avait inconnu. Il suffit de résoudre
cet aspect non connu. Ça passe par se confronter
à cet inconnu justement, ça peut se faire
de manière très simple comme changer quelques
habitudes et sortir de sa zone de confort,
mais ça peut aussi se faire en se cultivant,
en discutant beaucoup avec ceux que l’on
pourrait considérer comme différent et en
s’intéressant à eux, leur vision des choses,
ça passe par les voyages.. Lire ça peut
grandement aider aussi, parce que ça permet
de vivre par procuration des vies qui sont
très loin des nôtres et d’avoir une meilleure
compréhension de tous les enjeux. Fait intéressant,
il y a une étude parue dans Psychological
Science qui explique que non seulement notre
langue maternelle influence fortement notre
vision du monde, ce qui parait extrêmement
logique, d’ailleurs je ferais forcément
une vidéo sur le langage, même si je ne
sais pas encore sous quelle forme. Mais elle
explique aussi qu’avoir une seconde langue
permet d’avoir une vision alternative du
monde. Donc forcément ça aide aussi à être
plus ouvert d’esprit.
Voilà, j'espère que cet épisode vous a plu ! Si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à le partager !
Vous pouvez aussi poser vos questions sur Twitter avec #ASKCyrusNorth ou bien en
commentaire de cette vidéo. Les questions
peuvent toucher à la philo,
la psycho, la science, tout.
ça me permet de réfléchir à des trucs aussi donc c’est
cool !
Je vous envoie du love et
de la peace ! Ciao ;)